vacciner vacciner vaccinés depuis des
semaines médecins et personnalités
publiques politiques se bousculent sur
les plateaux de télévision pour marteler
cette injonction qui pourra peut-être
nous permettre de sortir de la crise du
coc vide 19 seulement voilà les vaccins
ils ont un coût sur rfi le secrétaire
d'état aux affaires européennes clément
boon a confirmé une information diffusée
par le financiel times selon laquelle
les vaccins pfizer et modern a avait
augmenté leurs prix dans le cadre d'un
accord avec l'union européenne
selon lui ce prix s'explique par
l'adaptation des vaccins aux variants et
aux conditions de production et de
livraison imposés au laboratoire
il faut regarder tout cela de manière
rationnelle ne pas se faire avoir
évidemment mais avoir des contrats plus
exigeants avec des produits adaptés aux
variants probablement oui mais pas
seulement pour l'union européenne pour
tous les acheteurs
ce sera un peu plus cher pour le
sécrétaire d'état l'europe qui achète de
très gros volumes de vaccin permet de
payer moins cher la dose que si c'était
les états eux mêmes qu'ils le faisaient
selon les informations du financial
times le vaccin pfizer devrait passer de
15,5 euros à 19,5 euros et celui de
modern à 2 19 euros à 21,5 euros
les vaccins devraient être gratuits lors
les transactions à leur sujet devons
être transparents et les brevets
devraient être publics
ils sont au service de l'humanité et
l'humanité ne doit pas être au service
des spéculations financières aux des
gros laboratoires pourquoi est ce qu'il
n'ya pas de vaccin en france depuis 20
mois
pourquoi est ce que nos chercheurs
depuis 2009 qui avait déjà touché au
coronavirus n'ont pas été aidés pourquoi
être le gouvernement n'a pas mis des
milliards en plus pour la recherche par
quatre mamans la sofred public dans ses
derniers résultats trimestriels la seule
société kaiser annoncé un chiffre
d'affaires de 18,9 milliards de dollars
sur l'ensemble de ses activités et
prévoit pour 2021 33,5 milliards de
dollars de chiffre d'affaires sur ses
ventes de vaccins développés avec bio
ntech bien plus que ce qui était espéré
par la société en mai et puisque la
crise semble s'éterniser que la
vaccination générale est présenté par
les autorités comme la seule réponse
crédible
pour endiguer l'épidémie certains font
désormais remarquer que ça commence à
coûter cher